[موسيقى]
كل شيء متصل ، كل شيء هو
طاقة تحتاج فقط إلى ضبطها
، وبعد ذلك يمكنك الحصول على أي معلومات
من الحيوانات من النباتات من الشجرة ،
يمكن طرح أي سؤال على الحيوان ،
نعم أعرف أنني أعرف
، وعندما أقوم بالشفاء في الغالب سيوجهون
سيخبرونني ماذا أفعل إلى أين أذهب
وكيف تكثف حتى الطاقة
[موسيقى
] الحالات التي سأتناولها اليوم هي
ببغاء رمادي يقوم أحدهم بإزالة
الريشة اسمه بابلو لم أقابله أبدًا
هذه هي المرة الأولى لي و  سأكتشف
معك في نفس الوقت ما يحدث
[موسيقى]
إنه خائف
وهذا ما أحصل عليه منه الآن حسنًا ،
آسف
لا بأس ، أعلم
حسنًا ، تعال إلى هذا إذا كنت تريد ،
نعم أعرف
ما أفعله الآن أعطي  طاقاته
أضع يدي على هذه المسافة حتى
يتمكن من تلقي الطاقة
التي يخبرني بها أنه لا ينام
جيدًا
، ولا يجد السلام ،
بل يستخدم الكلمات في مرحلة ما ، لكنه
يعطيني أيضًا
شعورًا بما يحدث بداخله.
العقل داخل جسده
أنا د  لا أشعر بالغثيان لأنني سألته عما إذا
كان بإمكانه أن يعطيني مشاعر ما
يحدث بالفعل في معدته ،
لا أفهم هذا
ولكن
معدتي تشعر بثقل ،
نعم ، أعلم
الآن أنه يعطي رسالة واضحة تخبرني
أنني "  أشعر أنني غير موجود ،
أود أن أسميها رفضًا بلغة البشر ،
هل لديك أي سؤال
له لماذا يزيل ريشه بشكل صحيح
للتخلص من التوتر الذي يقول
إنه يعرض لي صورًا
أريد أن آخذ بشرتي هكذا كما
تعلمون  أنا أنفجر من الداخل ،
لا أعرف كيف أتعامل مع هذا
القلق
الزائد ، وعندما أفعل هذا ،
أخيرًا ،
أقترح
عليك التحدث إليه
ولكن التحدث إليه كما أتحدث الآن
أنت من يحتاج
أود أن أقول بذل الجهد وابدأ في
إعادة الاتصال ،
حسنًا ،
أنت أيضًا بحاجة إلى تغيير وضعه ،
إنه لا يشعر بالرضا هناك ،
وجدنا أنه يعاني قليلاً من التوتر
وحاولنا أن
نجعله رفيقة رائعة ليلى كانت مولعة بهورام كثيرًا  أن بابلو شعر
بالوحدة قليلاً أو أنه أصبح
أقل انتباهاً
لقد شعرت بخيبة أمل بعض الشيء لأننا
حاولنا منح بابلو كل شيء على الإطلاق من
جميع أنواع الفصول
والإمداد وجميع أنواع الرفاهية ،
لذلك أعتقد أننا سنجري تغييرًا في هذا
الموقف ونرى ما سيحدث
[موسيقى]